Mark Anthony and his wife former Miss
Universe Nadia Ferreira are expecting
their first child together this is just
a blessing two weeks after the couple
said I do in Miami they announced Nadia
is pregnant posting this sweet photo of
her baby bump with their hands gently
resting on it and writing best
Valentine's gift ever thank you God for
this big blessing in our lives
[Applause]
the new bundle of joy will be the 23
year old model's first child and the
singer seventh proud papa Mark first
became a proud papa in 1994 when he and
his then partner Debbie Rosado welcomed
their daughter Ariana one year later son
Chase joined the fam when Mark and
Debbie went their separate ways he moved
on with another former Miss Universe
dayonara Torres they tie the knot in
2000. me being able to be by his side it
just means a lot to me they share two
sons Christian and Ryan but divorced in
2004. that same year mark married
Jennifer Lopez
they went on to have twins Max and Emmy
but the couple called it quits in 2011.
how did Jennifer put it she said Emmy
sings like me and Max has her
personality yeah I think Max is going to
be like her manager though or her
bodyguard you and Mark Anthony have like
this like um a not together couple thing
down pat oh yeah no we're we're like
best friends for Mark balancing a career
and six kids has had its share of
challenges it's something he opened up
about on CBS This Morning in 2020. the
one regret
uh
would be that what I chose to do took so
much of my time what I would have done
to have been a stay-at-home dad and just
you know witness every second of
everything you sort of start to wonder
was it all worth it
how do you answer that
um
I don't think you do by 2022 Mark gave
love another chance when he proposed to
Nadia in May eight months later they got
hitched and seemed happier than ever
with their little one on the way it's
just the beginning congrats to Nadia and
Mark on their growing family
[Music]
thank you